alors tu vas
m'écrire une fille qu'en vaut la peine
c'est dur à
[Musique]
trouver pas si tu sais où chercher tu
manqueras
chaquee Majan vous étiez le premier
pilote affecté au cè avec vous êtes à la
tête de 35 appareils et de 350 hommes
d'équipage je mourir avant que
j'arrive quelque chose d'énorme se
prépare la 8e va envoyer la plus grande
armada aérienne jamais réunie dans
l'histoire de l'humanité au cœur de
l'Allemagne
hitlérienne nous devons avoir une totale
maîtrise du ciel c'est ça la
mission quoi c'est peut-être le dernier
joli minois que je
vois
touch
touch on fait quoi
alors on ramène nos gars
entiers tout ce qu'on
fait jour après jour ça laisse forcément
des trace non on doit combattre la bête
quand on voit de quoi ces gens sont
capables
on se dit qu'ils l'ont bien cherché
croyez-moi Seigneur ve sur nos hommes
dans les air le protection et
lumièrealab
pas reste toujours à le côté dans le
souffle des
temptes
CI battra jusqu'au
bout y